and the thing about a comprehensive
narrative is it can't leave out an
archetypal character or it failed I can
give you an example of this okay so how
many of you have seen Disney Sleeping
Beauty okay so so many of you have how
many happened okay so so they confuse it
happen well the Disney movies you know
they're kind of standard childhood fare
you know in Sleeping Beauty what happens
is the king and queen give birth to a
princess after trying for a substantial
amount of time and you know she arrives
healthy and beautiful and then they have
a christening day and they invite
everybody to it but they don't invite
Melissa who's dark which roughly
speaking you know like she's a she's
queen of the underworld that for lack of
a better word she's the negative
elements of femininity and they don't
invite her to the party
and so she shows up anyways and says
that because they didn't invite her
their daughter's going to die when when
she had sixteen which is roughly the age
of let's say sexual maturation for a
story of that sort
now there's another little positive
magic female in the story who mitigates
that death sentence too protracted sleep
while the idea behind it it's a very
very interesting story it's an eatable
story in a sense which is what it says
is that if your parents protect you too
much from the dark side of life
when you're young that what will happen
when you start to on the road to
maturity is you'll be so naive and so
fragile that you'll want to be
unconscious instead of paying attention
and that you're going to have to be
rescued from that state by something and
it could be a prince which is one which
is how that story lays itself out or it
also could be that symbolically
masculine and exploratory element of
your own psyche and the stories are
ambivalent about whether it's an
external event or an internal and it
doesn't really matter you know that the
things end up being the same and so
that's actually what happens in this
the Sleeping Beauty story you know at
the end a prince who's also enslaved by
this terrible negative feminine force
manages to escape and the Maleficent
turns into a dragon and he has to fight
her and then he goes and rescues the
princess and she wakes up and the
kingdoms rejuvenated and everybody's
happy it's a classic classic story you
know and it's not funny because the
Disney movie frozen was put forward as a
in some sense as a feminist alternative
to the classic fairy tales at first of
all you can't do that you can't just
generate up a fairy tale you know
there's recent evidence that some of
these fairy tales the ones that the
Grimm brothers and the FN haves
Christian Andersen collective are up to
10,000 years old
you can't just come up with a counter
fairy tale that's that's just not how it
works and the way that fairy tale is
structured it has nothing to do with
with the necessity for anyone to rely on
anyone else for anything it's a complex
portrayal of the denies dynamic
relationship between archetypal
characters and you know it's one form of
the story there's lots of different
forms of the story but what I like about
Sleeping Beauty for example and this is
what's nice about the real fairy tales
is that along with the positive there is
negative and it's real negative like
real fairy tales are terrifying like I
don't who is it this is Ben Sleeping
Beauty or in Snow White I don't remember
in one of the famous script fairy tales
one of the evil sisters ends up dancing
in red hot shoes till she dies you know
it's they're very very violent and and
unsettling and it's because they you
know they have the quality of genuine
folktales but the reason for that is
because they're dealing with real things
but the Hansel and Gretel story is a
good example of that right kids are
abandoned out in the woods they find
something that's too good to be true
inside this thing that's too good to be
truly something that wants to fatten
them up and devour them it's a rough
story but what it's doing is the stories
the stories have evolved to rip
fundamental dynamic elements of
existence if you conceptualize existence
in in terms of character and the thing
is you have to conceptualize existence
in terms of characters if you're a
person because what you do in existence
is act out your character so your
character is an element of existence now
you might say well that doesn't mean
that society has a character but
actually it does mean that and because
partly what happens like if you're
socialized say into a culture the
culture exists in the same relationship
to you roughly speaking as another
person does so for example if you put
money in the bank which is in principle
a representation of your labor what
you're doing is entering into a contract
with the broader social world which is
one of promise essentially where the
future society promises to return your
value at a future date so it's a
contractual relationship and the reason
that God the Father is a very common
representation is because treating the
same in HIDA garyun terms the others in
HIDA garyun terms as if they're an
embodied entity actually works